[Musique]
c'est super d'être de retour c'est tellement bon d'être
là
même avec des masques je viens d'en trouver un qui
allait avec mon cosplay qu'il porte comme si
c'était le vrai métal
[Musique]
c'est du cosplay ça me manque de cosplayer
m'habiller avec mes amis qui arrivent  ici
en tant que groupe manquant particulièrement les panneaux
et voir tous mes artistes préférés tous
mes mangaka préférés et aimer jouer à des
jeux vidéo et simplement rencontrer beaucoup de
personnes uniques intéressantes qui partagent le
même intérêt que vous parce qu'il est vraiment
difficile de trouver des gens en dehors de la bande dessinée con
qui partagent les mêmes intérêts que vous
[Musique]
et je ne peux pas porter ça au supermarché
d'habitude, donc c'est très agréable d'être avec
des gens qui connaissent la mode ou qui
s'y intéressent aussi et je peux sortir et aimer
défiler c'est très  fun
[Musique]
vous